Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, and this is episode 11 in my personal journey, and
I'm going to share with you
a poem that God gave me that is
that is
really from my heart to
my family, my wife, my patients,
my friends, my staff,
my acquaintances, and I really pray that God is
changing me every day that this poem can be
my heartfelt wish for what I can be in your life.
So, it's called that I may be
and I want to share it with you.
So, let's do that.
May I be a source of hope to help you see beyond the stars.
May I inspire you to write, to look inside your soul so far.
That you discover needs that only God above can fill.
May my life reveal to you someone surrendered to his will.
When you need a touch, let me be there to hold your hand.
And when you lack of strength,
beside you, I will stand.
When happy, we'll share joy.
Overwhelmed, I'll comfort you.
But it feels that you're abandoned.
You'll know that I am true.
While your entire world is crumbling,
and heavy is the day, I'll be beside you.
Let our deeds lead us both to pray.
We'll walk the difficult, traverse what seems immense,
come through it all with scars, but wiser now, and cleansed.
Then we'll gaze upon Almighty with eyes that see now clear.
We'll stand upon the streets of gold, and shed a little tear.
But not in sorrow anymore.
Enjoy that rumbles deep from spots inside of us that once were fast asleep.
We'll eat from trees that healed the woods of yesterday.
Our bodies now renewed as children we will play.
We'll dance the clouds with angels, we'll sing songs we've never heard.
We'll know love that's indescribable by any human words.
We'll know and see and hear the things impossible to write.
A human heart could not contain the width, the depth, the height.
So now, before we get there, let's just contemplate the view.
But this I pray that I may be the hand of God to you.